[Musique]
alors je m'appelle Cécile Galien je suis
maire de voré sur Arzon c'est une
commune de Haute-Loire et je suis très
attachée à ce beau département qui est
dans le Massif Central est situé entre
le Puy-de-Dôme et l'Ardèche j'y suis
maire depuis 2008 je suis aussi
vice-président de l'Association des
maires de France en charge de la
commission des communes et territoires
ruraux j'ai été également conseillère
départemental de la Haute-Loire et je
suis saxophoniste dans la banda de Vorey
depuis que je suis en âge de jouer du
saxophone ou de la musique c'est-à-dire
l'âge de 6 ans j'ai commencé à faire des
études d'économie en fait à la faculté
de Saint-Étienne et puis j'ai eu un DESS
d'aménagement du territoire et ça a été
ma passion et c'est toujours ma passion
la politique m'a me plaît parce que déjà
au niveau familial on écoutait beaucoup
la télé les échanges les uns des autres
je suis centr on va dire
de naissance j'ai monté une liste en
2008 même si ce n'était pas une
obligation une disparitaire autant de
femmes que d'hommes avec des compétences
très diverses des âges différents des
responsabilités différentes des loisirs
différents et c'est comme ça en fait
qu'on a pu notre premier mandat trouver
des médecins créer une maison de santé
alors être mère c'est presque habité
avec avec les habitants c'est à dire on
est au cœur de leur moment de bonheur
par exemple des mariages mais aussi leur
moment de difficultés ou quand un jeune
et bien essaye de trouver un stage ou on
a aussi la chance de voir des porteurs
projets qui veulent venir s'installer
dans nos communes je pense qu'en fait
être maire c'est animé cette cellule
vivante qui est une commune mon job
c'est fait en sorte que ce corps vivant
qui est la commune soit en bonne santé
reste en bonne santé ça veut dire qu'il
faut qu'il se développe les gens du cru
y soient bien que les nouveaux habitants
y soient bien que chacun y trouve sa
place et essayer d'épanouisse